yes yes but it changes notice they
tossed material in a second and
apparently it only takes them I mean
we've been playing this game for 600
years and apparently all it takes is
four hours yes indeed let's talk about
alpha zeros accomplishment what do you
see the meaning behind alpha zero being
able to stock fish after only looking at
the game for four hours with no other
human intervention whatsoever
well obviously the sport our thing is
not too relevant though it's a nice
punchline but it's obviously very
powerful hardware so this is equivalent
to my laptop sitting for a couple of
decades I think the more relevant thing
is that it figured everything out from
scratch and that is the scary and
promising if you look at it why do you
say that what is a scary and promising
because I would like to think that there
should be a little bit harder
it feels annoying that you can work
things out from just the rules of just
in that quickly and the implication for
other areas I don't know to be Nestor I
also don't have a lot of details that
are I'd like to know more about the the
conditions under which stockfish played
and what exactly happened but if
suddenly what is very impressive is this
that it sees so few positions alpha zero
seeing eighty thousand positions per
second so somehow this is back to the
human approach because the root for the
pro I mean they were crushing us with
brute force as well but if some sort of
mixture of training are computed to do
it in a human-like thought process that
is fascinating but like I said I'd like
to see more info now I'd like them to
explain this a bit better I read the
paper and was in comprehensible to me
challenges well twenty years on since
the computer are now more than twenty
years
computer has defeated
the deep loop the Phoebus tomorrow we're
used to engines beating us at chess is
that an issue for us now that officer
was able to to do this and all I did was
beat starfish which conference was
already beating all the best players
know there is no evil hassle for us
anymore we are that train has left the
station we I don't I don't think any
human being even fancies that he has
such I mean if you play a hundred games
in stock fish will be happy to draw one
so that is pretty much hopeless and the
fact that we are losing with extra
material as well that for me is even
more annoying because I would think if
you give me a pawn I should be able to
do you know I should be able to hold on
but that even that with two pawns and
all that you are not able to beat them
but this is very interesting because
they suddenly it opens the door to some
maybe even imposing the computer some
intelligent questions instead of always
having to look at its conclusions and
then try to figure out all the answers
yourself imagine not a conversation but
some sort of intelligent querying could
reveal very interesting things about
chess it's just very early to say but
fascinating is the implications for
top-level chess the possibility that one
of your colleagues might get a hold of
this technology before you do well you
worried about anything like that I
haven't gotten that far yet
but it's interesting it might reveal a
whole lot of new things about chess
especially these few games they released
this Queen's Indian defense it's
fascinating
well I'll have to tell you the moves the
one where it goes Queen g4 night at six
shaking g7 NBC three and black is
completely underdeveloped and then black
wins the head six night and all white
has is pure peace play so the two rooks
the two bishops on the Queen and black
is under developer the whole piece up
and and what's fascinating though means
that stockfish keeps on saying it's
equal so it thinks that White has to
repeat
and I don't know I'm not able to
understand what alpha is alpha zero
seeing because it it could be seeing
that it's a win already or simply we
could be playing on because it thinks
it's worth playing on I mean it's almost
a human way of approaching it like I
said for the moment the far more
questions and answers but it's it's the
first exciting thing that's happened in
computer computers playing chess in a
long time because as you pointed out I
mean since 97 they can beat us faster
and a smaller amount that's it's not
that interesting
this suggests that they're little things
to be learnt about this Z well thanks
very much for sharing all your insights
with us and good luck with the rest of
your games yeah thank you thank you